hello how's it going everybody
welcome to another night of chess on
psychology
today i kind of decided to take a little
uh trip down the memory lane of the us
championship 2018
it was particularly painful for me
um but i learned a lot from it and it
was one of the first times i was playing
most of these opponents
so i think that was a very educational
tournament for me
but uh besides that another kind of
awesome thing that it had for me was i
got such i got
a lot of great games out of it uh not
necessarily i managed to
get away from with winning um
as much as i got good positions but i am
quite proud
of how i played so i think it's kind of
fitting to
um take a look at that since well
tomorrow us championship starts and i'm
gonna have to face most of this well
actually
not most of them a lot of the a lot of
the um
opponents and changed so we'll see how
it goes
but uh so this was actually 2018's us
championship
first round when i was playing anna sure
actually i saw anna recently when i say
recently i mean like
this year somewhere like five six months
ago at this point
um just she was walking down central
west end it was so funny
um i was sitting i was walking my cat
she was walking her dog
and we just ran into each other and it
was just one of those really funny
moments and for a second i was like i
was just like i knew her and i was like
oh my god first name last name but she
remembered and she said my name
perfectly and
well i know her i know her name and just
it was just one of those
um brain moments
so yeah um let's dive into
this game it was a very uh
it was really funny just how the game
unfolded actually let me
mute from here so
um unlike this here
back in 2018 when i wanted when i was
uh invited to play u.s championship i
was extremely ambitious not that i'm not
ambitious
now it's just i have so much during
school year
i got mcat the book is actually right
here so
um yeah it's it's a i sleep with my
books i wake up one front of books it's
it's a
yeah it's not the best timing for me but
well just yeah so
um so back in 2018 i was actually very
ambitious i was very hopeful
i yeah i was working with some of the
teammates and i was doing like
some deep analysis new openings
preparations
oh god i was so cute
and so for example here one of my
preparations
was to actually do this f3 which i did
over the board
and i had prepared it i had i've had
training games
i knew what i was doing i remembered the
openings
yeah so i actually uh prepared for this
tournament like a real chess player
instead of this college student um
so um i think anna was quite surprised
because
i've never played this in my life before
over the boil i mean rated games that
would be um
that would be um saved somewhere
so yeah yeah this is the kind of
i saw that so i thought this was played
recently in
some of the top level chess too so that
was kind of interesting that kind of
inspired me to i believe it was a
norwegians
i don't remember exactly who played it
so if you do
please type it in the chat and i'll say
that about too
but i saw that this happened recently in
one of the final rounds of the norway
chess 2.
again i'm 99 sure there's a one percent
i've dreamt of i've been having serious
weird dreams eating kasparov losing on
time losing because my camera stopped
working
yeah um so anyways
uh in this specific game oh hi kitty
well
you're character's instructor just
showed up this will be fun to play with
tomorrow in the us championships
um so after
thank you kitty you might want to um
yeah
so in this specific game i think uh
i don't it's i remember queen b6
are the most interesting ones
um yeah and people also like there's a
take an e5 there are like so many
different
lines to play i believe um i think queen
b6
is one of the most annoying ones uh if i
remember correctly
nope not that that's not the right uh
move i was going for if i remember
correctly uh taking an e5
or e5 immediately is also a thing
because you want to do queen h4
yeah oh yeah e5 immediately probably i
mean that
looks decent because you just want to do
cleanest four
so i think there are a lot of different
variations to consider
and the cat sleeps in front of me oh
actually i like this just i don't think
my book will appreciate him
his 13 and a half pounds
okay um sorry a4
uh a4 um
queen b6
um i am not familiar with the with the
most recent theory in this line but i do
know that queen b6
lines do exist i think knight c3
is the easiest way to go i believe you
could do some weird stuff with knight e2
as well
but ah okay so you could do e5 and queen
v6 yeah
that is also yeah i think that's one of
the scary thoughts as well not
necessarily just finished four but
to try and go this way
so yeah um i think well
what i was going for i was basically um
going for the element of surprise and i
was just hoping that
this would be the game that would start
off my tournament pretty cool
and you know all those fun thoughts that
you have when you
are a newbie and you are hopeful
yeah thank you this was actually pretty
nice line um so
i ended up just going for c3 i believe
this was also preparation
and i simply followed up by bishop
f4 so it's my understanding that bishop
f4 i was just trying to block e5
i think from what i remember again it's
been like two years and
i don't exactly remember what was i
thinking this was played in 2018 u.s
championships i
i i'm hoping to be able to show you guys
two games from that tournament
um the most the most painful two games
i had some less painful games too um but
yeah so um in this specific game
i think i thought of the show before
over the board because i really didn't
like the idea of e5 and i could not
remember what am i supposed to do after
g6
so i believe bishop g5 is the best way
to stop
e5 i think that's the best way if you
are looking to playing this
yeah it's just as harsh not this hard
not as harsh as mcat though i'm kind of
just so it's just
it's taking away my sleep i dream about
it
i have nightmares about it i wake up
thinking about it
i have dark circles already about it oh
man
i miss being 18. okay but
anyway so after bishop f4 um
she took and then she played e5 so i
believe that she
made a miscalculation or she mis
evaluated the position because now after
take
even when you take the queen and i take
back this is
still this is still i mean i like my
position there's nothing
wrong with my position so why would
black just go ahead and give up this
pawn
i don't i wouldn't recommend that i
don't think she was quite happy with her
position after this anyways
so she ended up playing um
bishop e6 which was a great move because
if my bishop got to c4
my bishop would be quite monstrous right
so
at this point i have no theory knowledge
but i just
i was just playing chess so the plan
that i made
was yeah exactly we gotta put the c2
exactly king on c2 on a pillow yeah
um no but so i thought that i have to
figure out what to do with my pieces
first of all this is clear it's really
winking at me so i would love to get a
piece up there
so if i could do like a knight f3 then
try to you know organize
something like that and try to get to d6
i thought that would be pretty cool
um whoops knight d7 knight d2
h6 so now i was like okay
do i want to play something like h4 to
stop g5s or do i want to ignore it and
go with knight c4 there are other
options over the board
too but my question my first question
for you guys is why to move what do you
want to do
so it's your choice how do you want to
continue this game
and i am going to stare at my cute cat
sleeping on my mcat
books
yeah um so
oh i see a bishop c4 i like bishop c4
i don't necessarily so vanessa i don't
necessarily like c4
uh i think c4 then so c4 is supposed to
be for the pieces because if i play pawn
c4 what if he plays pawn c5 and then
i can't really use that i did
like h4 idea but my problem with the
move h4 over the board
was that then i would give up this g4
square
so if by any chance to decide to get
creative and guts your knight on g4
i don't really want to deal with that so
that was kind of my big thing
um i don't agree with king c2 right away
because
i feel like that would be a waste of
time well
not necessarily for i don't think king
c2 is the right time
it's just we don't really need this king
c2
like nobody is forcing me nobody is
threatening anything on me so why would
i go king c4
pc2 so that's kind of why
i am i actually do king c2
but um i kind of
wanted to continue with the idea of
going after this d6 square just i wasn't
necessarily sure how
knight b3 no i think we should we should
go something on c4
either knight c4 or bishop c4 now which
one do you think is best i saw
that there are different ideas in chats
knight c4 bishop c4s
but which one do you guys think is the
best one
yeah you shouldn't rush it i think
that's the thing too
okay so i see a bunch of knight sea
force
i guess you guys will be surprised to
know i did knight c4 and it was not the
best move
because the thing is when you go nice c4
what are you going to do with your
bishop you have to you have to
you have to take into account that this
bishop is always going to be a weakness
in your position and
i might say one of the big weaknesses so
if you considered if you consider your
double cons of weakness then your bishop
is also a
super weakness so it is a good idea to
try and get rid of it especially because
this bishop this blacks bishop is also
the best
um piece in his position so
just thinking about it logically
strategically not even calculating it
it would be a good idea to exchange
these bishops because this bishop
i don't really i can't really do much
with it that bishop
is actually doing something useful
compared to most of black's other pieces
so that is why bishop c4 would have been
best
and after bishop c4 um if you
well if you take it that would be
awesome i'll just get that knight to d6
please
give me all the pawns um i
i don't anticipate taking uh i'm
assuming like 97
um take potentially take
and maybe now knight c4
short cast though for example um you
move this guy
he pushes that guy i mean you still have
a lot of advantage that's why don't get
me wrong but it's still i mean it
doesn't
feel as strong so knight e7 would be the
better choice compared to
taking this bishop but anyways bishop c4
still would have been the best choice
so i didn't do this i went knight c4 i
saw this is square
i just wanted to have my knight in there
no questions asked
so i went knight c4 um
she played g5 well i gotta move the
bishop knight e7
all right check and now at this position
i was like okay
so i know uh i know i don't want to
give my opponent activity i know i have
advantage i know
i have at least plus two advantage and i
was correct
uh this position is plus two but it's
just figuring out
how to win it i had issues there
so i didn't have an issue
getting an advantage i had an issue
converted at that
advantage to a full win so um
in the game i considered knight to b7
obviously but
my problem was well okay rp8
now what to do if i go bishop a6 well
this one is
still pretty weak so you could simply
play something like
knight g6 and start going after this guy
and i kind of stopped my calculations
here which was wrong i should have
pushed and i should have seen
simply knight before that was the
easiest way to
continue this another thing to con to
consider is king c2 so the take
rook creates there is no more threat so
that's what i actually did i went kings
d2
and my idea was pretty simple i just
wanted
to uh defend my b2 and yeah that is
actually a very
s that's such a great thing thank you
guys you're saying
so many good things and yes actually
accepting the mistake and playing bishop
c4 was the best choice
in the game uh she played rook b8
defending the pawn now i should have
played this bishop c4
like i shouldn't have delayed it and i
delayed it and
then it was uh like you can imagine i'm
sure that has happened to you at
12. i hope you've learned from it
because
i take like these to me were quite
um i mean i didn't take them the best
also i was
super hopeful and i thought i was super
ready
and so it's kind of had a huge turn on
my tournament
overall and also in my emotional state
but the problem wasn't that i wasn't
playing bad chess the problem was that i
expected too much and i couldn't see
realistically
so in this position realistically i'm
plus two
i i shouldn't but i still have to
convert it
which i didn't so um i think the easiest
way to do would be bishop c4 if you
don't see bishop c4
just rook d1 because i wasn't seeing
that exact
plan i couldn't really um i couldn't
really
um get that i couldn't really just
calm down and find the right move that
the position needs and i was just trying
to do
what uh whatever i could to form an
attack
um yeah this was us championship 2018.
i thought it would be a good trip down
the memory lane
i believe that's how americans say it um
for since the my tournament us
championship starts tomorrow
i thought it would be interesting review
of
what happened to me back then and
hopefully how to avoid it this time
um all right so
uh what else want to show there was one
specific thing i wanted
to get deeper ah yes
so not root d1 actually um
so i think the
one thing that i should have done was
rick d1 but i didn't
and um what i did
was i
played knight d4 94
started to kind of get a little iffy it
wasn't going so pretty anymore
and i kind of lost that balance
so that was a huge thing that i lost
that balance
and um yeah
i didn't really enjoy that i i kind of
like lost the pace coordination the
balance the rhythm of the position
and um knight d4 didn't really go well
with any of the plans that i had
i should have been simply with bishop c4
if you take it
okay i'll take it back everything is
defended
i can start trying to throw stuff around
here
i still have one more pawn everything
seems to be going well
that's what i should have done um
however
what i actually did was
um this
94 i'm still a little new to
leeches so and sometimes i get lost on
what i'm trying to show
uh but yeah and i think knight d4 was a
painful move to make
yeah knight d4 and she just played
knight g6
simple stuff so i want to ask you guys
so why to move
what do you think we should do keep in
mind you still have one extra pawn your
position is still pretty great
but your opponent is beginning to fight
back
so what should we do
oh hi i'm annie i don't know why i
thought i think i saw that i
i gave you a mental response um
yes it's so hard to be anything
but enjoying right now with this
super cute cat sleeping right here
wiggling his tail showing me that he's a
little awake but not too much
ah clutter what is the kitty's name
tishi
yeah so i think 96 is interesting rook
t1 is interesting
bishop c4 again should have been
considered
so yeah i'm kind of asking you guys so
what do you think we should go for
uh that's a good point can i keep the
pawn huh
um well i guess it kind of depends on
how you continue
because if you were to play well that's
true but if you were to play bishop c4
uh something like take take and
for example take on e5 see if the knight
takes on e5
then i still can't fight it with
something like knight d6
and it gets really tricky because of
this pin and you can't really move the
roof because you lose the pawn
so i think that would have been the
something like the
one of the best ways to um
get it get the pawn but um
yeah let's see what else what else
instead of bishop c4
taking take and
then
the problem is my pieces really don't
have coordination so if i were to play
something like bishop c4 now
just king e7 and i don't really see
a way i think actually black is doing it
a little bit better here
so i don't think this isolated pawn
would actually help me in
any case because i also have two of it
so
i mean it's not like i can attack it and
in this position because
this the center is still pretty close
and black is too nice
black is the one who would be fighting
for um
getting better so
huh yeah i wasn't the biggest fan of my
position at this point either
and i kept thinking where did i go wrong
because i did everything right i
developed i put the king safe i got the
knight in there
i'll post so where did it go wrong so
that was what i was trying to figure out
and i couldn't really
make it work and
so that was a problem and um i
eventually
kind of at this point i made a weird i
mean i think rook d1 should have still
been the move
because even if you take on um
e5 which is what most likely would
happen
now i could try to like trick you with
something like bishop v2 because we
still have that pin that i mentioned a
little before
and that pin would still be pretty
annoying i could try with rickett ones
and stuff like that if you take it with
the other knight
same i could just try to maybe do
bishops d4
take take and the knight is still
planned right
i think this would have been an
interesting chance yeah that's that was
so i remember i remember considering
these moves
but i just didn't like it so i ended up
playing actually bishop e2 my idea was i
still wanted to use this pin
uh given the chance but the problem was
that will bishop b5
black wasn't gonna risk this black was
just gonna take
and i mean just take with bishop so
no no pinning um
i simply ended up going entering this
position
and um knight f4
so what what do you guys think about
this position now do you want to be
white do you want to be black
and it is white to move so if you have a
move please suggest it
okay um
i'm reading the chess and it's really
interesting so i'm getting a lot of
knight c4s
i open up yeah that's ideally i want to
open up i got two bishops but i
i don't really see how
yeah i see exactly thank you arthur it
does look
better but um
honestly this position is kind of equal
i mean really i mean if everybody if
both sides play accurately
obviously but if somebody makes a
mistake then yeah well
this is still a very sharp position so i
just went to knight c4 because well i
gotta
save that light right and i played e5
my idea was well i might as well try to
eat this knight
so e5 i was laying a little bit of
trap 2 if knight takes e5 now i would
simply have
um somewhere with like just trying to
maneuver the bishop around a little i
think i thought that was kind of cool
um or i could just take bishop f4
i don't think bishop f4 would have much
to it however
um just k7 and well this would be a
very dry game
um i don't really anticipate much blood
shedding
but after e5's anna played king e7 so
why to
what what do you think we should do my
first choice is to take over here
yep this is kind of dead drop i agree
take take i
took b5 ah here i made
i did a very interesting move i played
drug f1 so
my thing was after rook f1 if you take
it it is so funny
ah check king e8 bishop h5
uh take for example rook d1
i thought this was such an interesting
line to calculate
i was so ready to go for it yeah exactly
but um she was smarter than that she
wouldn't
she wouldn't let me get into this
position why would she
grab a piece just to be suffering all
through it
right so i think this was one of those
uh moves that i think if i was playing
like a
lower rated uh well actually that's not
if i was playing someone with a
huge difference in level
and just understanding then most likely
the opponent's like ah free piece well
let's take it why not
and that would be a very interesting um
way to win this game actually for white
but she was smarter than that
she understand she understood the
position she understood that this
position doesn't really have much to
offer
all she has to do is well not
um not overreach and we
just exchanged the rooks well i gotta
save my night
and um this ended in a very
reasonable draw like i i don't really i
mean i think this is as
as draw as the position gets honestly
uh but yeah this was a very interesting
game not exactly my most favorite
chess my most favorite game ever
but i think it was a very good um i
think
i think i mean now that look at look at
it it was very educational just how
to decide between knight c4 or bishop c4
because
like there's so many different rules
that
they teach you when you are
developing your chess but at the same
time they don't exactly help you
identify well which one should you use
well so that was a big thing that i
struggled with a lot
um that i couldn't distinguish like
should i use what i learned or should i
like trust my gut
and eventually uh i was like you know
what i'm gonna trust my goods and that's
i think that was a one of those um
big chest revelations so if your gut is
good enough
um actually trust your guts okay
so let's go ahead and take and look at
i think this was my most painful game
no no no my most painful game was losing
the the world youth title
but one of my top five most painful
games
in chess oh god that was
such a painful game okay
am i mentally prepared to look at it
probably not
but we'll go ahead so this game was i
played against irina crush
she is a very um strong grandmaster
she has i'm sure everybody knows her so
i'm not gonna give her like a huge
introduction i got crushed exactly
that's
it yeah but i was crushing and then at
some point i was just kind of just went
like a balloon style
all right so again back in the
last tournament i was so so creative
i prepared so much i learned a whole new
opening repertoire
grim felt uh again
yeah that was funny um
so i i prepared this i
enjoyed playing it i would very much
like to play it again
i thought this positions were such an
interesting position
and she is she is a very strong chess
player no doubt there
um oh well hello i guess the only way to
win my buns is with the cuteness of the
cat
so uh
well fishy you wanna maybe
give me some room to see the board honey
thank you thank you um
d5 instead of d6 well i have
uh to be honest i have tried a lot of
different
openings um i've tried a lot of
different
like the the kings and kings indian
style klings indian style nimzo
d5 some weird b5s
just i think this is um that
this is what really suits me so i really
enjoyed this queen b6 ideas
with the fianchetto honestly i don't
know
i don't know like what would make me not
play this oh i guess when
i'm preparing for opponents really
depends on the opponent but
ideally i think this is a good choice to
do so this idea with queen v6
i believe there are a lot of interesting
gruntful books have also came out
for beginners um for beginners i would
recommend center
e4 you do e5 well i was white you
try with e4 and add some tricky d4s just
to get
for beginners really depends on the
level because i have i i know some
beginners who have trouble
uh mating they don't know how to mate
but i know some some people who are
who i would say they're beginner but um
they're a very different level they know
how to win the game just the whole
concept of knowing to win the game and
the different
uh some of the different checkmate ideas
that i think that's a huge
difference level okay
uh what is your my
final style
i mean it really depends on the game the
opponent that i'm playing
if i see a game and she or he has a bad
result in a
fiance with the queen side believe me
i'm going for that
if it's for the king side i'll go for
that but all right so i i really wanna
this is a very long game this is like
almost 17 moves oh hi kitty so i do want
to try and get
to as much as possible
ah this is so fun well meet your new
instructor
who he is actually putting his
head under my hand to pet him he's
demanding head drops
all right i'll drop your head to the
other hand actually yuki you come
okay um so
well actually uh in the games
uh irina went for b3
b3 is also a very good choice there's
nothing absolutely nothing wrong with b3
and after b3 i went for bishop 5.
so i think i had a pretty decent
understanding of this opening
and my um my idea was well
my bishop is great my other bishop is
also pretty great
my night is gonna get pretty cool the
other night
also i'll find something for it so i
really enjoyed my position i don't know
about you but i really like it
so right now we are just developing
38 i thought this was also pretty cool
um and finally knight e4
so after knight e4 uh i think
here was one of the interesting points
of the game
so she played e3 which was a little bit
um i don't want to say wrong or
unorthodox i think unorthodox is the
right
word because usually when you have g3
you don't really want to do e3 unless
you absolutely have to
so that's just one of the things that
has always bothered me
about e3 and g3 because right now i
don't
really have this any sort of serious
attack on your pawn i mean i'm attacking
it with two things you're defending it
do
two things voila um
but i also don't uh don't think white
wants to be under pressure so i don't
really see whites doing something like
c5s especially because well
doing c5 you have to keep in mind
one of the i'm going to give you a
little hint about this game because i
want to ask you questions and this
was one of my favorite games but also
one of the
most painful games so i guess that's
kind of the combination to go for um
keep in mind like as black i don't
really have that many weak pieces or
weak pawns
but white sauce this piece is undefended
nobody's defending this piece so this
could potentially
give me some ideas for you know some
cool knight c5 stuff
um she does have to do something with
the queen that is correct
but my idea was maybe you could delay it
maybe you could um bill i agree queen c2
is not possible
but maybe you would delay this whole
idea with e3
and just try to do
uh try to maybe get a little bit more
space in the king side
but i don't necessarily think a lot of
people would enjoy this line
so anywho um she played e3
knight d7 and now like to move
what is the first move that you are
thinking about
and not just shooting moves just a move
that you
that you would put as your first
candidate
huh nobody's saying the move that i did
interesting
well i think knight c5 is immediately
off the board because well
the pawn takes exactly you need that's
how that's how you kind of
uh find moves if you think about a move
knight c5
like huh well i see by the pawn takes
attacking my queen that's a horrible
blunder
so you gotta move your queen and
keep thinking about um
continuously actively think about now
what has changed in white's position is
this a new
uh defender's piece that i could
potentially um
go after no 92 bishop before
your knight on e4 is much better than
the white's knight why would you go for
it exactly
queen a6 see when you start talking to
yourself you figure stuff out
i don't think that applies for most
things in life but in chess
when you think about when you um
silently
talk to yourself you figure stuff out
but yeah queen a6 i think it was a very
interesting thing to do because
see i'm pinning that also pinning bats
knight c5s are beginning to get
um funny and she actually missed it she
played a3
and now boom knight c5
i spent so much time thinking which
knight would be better to take to c5
this one or the other one
and i just landed on the d1 because
it was more aggressive it was uh just
more um activity more space
open the rook and i i really liked
to have this night so now i might want
to take and then play knight e4 as well
so it kind of gives me that flexibility
take take and after that
uh she simply played knight d2
so i think 92 was particularly
interesting because you got to defend
this pawn at the same time
you had to save your knights you had to
um
you're attacking the other pawn so i
think this was interesting but what do
you guys think about taking on c5
do you think this is something that
could
happen or is black simply just winning
now
what what means you miss um i think she
missed the idea of knight c5 and that's
why she played a3
otherwise you could have simply played
um
just moved i was attacking the pawn that
is correct
uh but i i wouldn't really take the pawn
because knight takes before rookie one
it's kind of
um why did you take it with the e pawn
oh well that's also a good question so
first of all
this position black is winning exactly
we take over here
and just bishop d3 that should be easy
enough
um why did i take it with the e pawn
exactly for that reason because i was
trying to lay traps and i wanted to open
up my rook so that was my idea i wanted
to get more space i could potentially
take it to the night
but if i take it to the night i don't
really have any threats
right now so that would give my opponent
a chance to kind of get away with it
just play like uh
just move this lights basically anywhere
and now the bishop is defended i'm not
really attacking anything
so i don't really want to give that time
to the opponent to run away
um oh the question here whoa that's a
lot of errors
um the question here on why
and why what did i mean by a3 she missed
it
well i mean 83 i think she missed it
because with a3
knight c5 if i was white i would never
allow my c5
um but how to stop it that is also a
great question
i think you have to kind of realize uh
it is quiz
queen a2 a serious threat
um
maybe you could consider taking over
here
and if the pawn takes now you have
knight g5 or knight h2 i think that g5
and now you're attacking e4 so if i take
on a2
you could just play rx2 so if i take a2
you're gonna play rook c3 this is
defended you have rook a1
i think this would have been a better
choice for black before white
and if takes now then i would have to
take it to bishop
but now white could simply play a3 class
knight c5s don't really work because
this bishop is defended
so i think she made the she made this uh
the
the move order wrong and she played a3
first
and we got into this position so now
white's uh waxy move you can see that
black's position is a little bit better
but how are you going to win this
yeah knight c5 is not an easy move i
agree
i was so proud of it and um
as you can probably see the results i
messed up the game
in time trouble and uh yeah this kind of
messed up my whole tournament but i was
very proud of my middle game skills
yeah i agree either e5 or knight d3 i
think those two
are the strongest ones i don't exactly
like e5
i think e5 overall the idea to open up
is good but i don't really
see any idea what to do after take
so i like the e5 idea but um
you got to calculate it but it doesn't
really work right now so you got to move
this line
well actually you don't really have to
because it's not really going to take it
but knight d3 is the best way to go
about it
knight d3 rook b1 now another question
shall we take this bishop keep in mind
if you take this bishop we are most
likely going to be able to eat
some pawns we could take take take on a3
or we could take take play like c5 and
attack over here
thank you aryan you got this yeah we
gotta take
take and c5 and i did this and i was
so so so proud of it because um
i could take on a3 there is a free pawn
right in front of me
but then this wouldn't have made it as
interesting
um so i think that was a very
good choice from my side to just not
always eat and c5 was the best one
ah i see some parsy chat
nice yeah c5
after c5 she simply took on e4 now
question which pawn should we eat
that is true patrick the the pawn would
most likely hang in
pretty much all the positions so i don't
think it matters as much
no actually um well first of all
my c5 is coming so we got to take it
that's the first move
and after take now what if we take
um if we were to
take um the
the d4 pawn so if i was to play bishop
takes d4
now we're close to a2 i do have an
interesting
um i have an interesting two bishops but
i the position is still pretty hard to
want to convert it to a full point
and so um
yeah okay so i see some stuff about
uh central park i see some stuff about
just eating the apon um so
i'm only just taking the a pawn is
easier because well
this one isn't well not that bad this
pawn isn't exactly
um going anywhere can we eat both that
is what i was hoping
for um so rookie two
queen b4 and in the game she played d5
she tried to save her central pawns
now black to move you got some choice to
make
um you also have to make a deep
calculation
on can you eat b3 that is the biggest
question
in this position because if you can't
eat b3 then the position is equal
black still does have a little bit of
advantage but
nothing nothing
it's not really going to help you much
because yes you have these two bishops
yes you have a stronger open center
but um not exactly so if you take
queen takes b3 knight c5 now what do you
want to do
because exactly
um so aryan i've seen some really
thoughtful comments from you so i would
like you
i would like to encourage you and
everybody else in the chat to actually
consider
well what should we do because um
can whites do this what do we think
about knight takes b7
hi good morning man it's dark outside
um i mean i'm sure there was morning
some somewhere
but yeah
what do you think one knight b7 can
weiss do this
keep in mind queen takes b7 there is d6
and then after d6 d takes e7 is
happening your a8
rook is getting weird
actually black did need to go for this
this was the best line for black and i
was quite proud to see this
that is true white can't but exactly
why is now what do you want to do
after d6 what is the strongest move
um there is a suggestion on anything
else besides taking and white is
actually better so you have to take you
can't just move the strip around
you gotta take it and now
like to move what do you want to do
and oh the strike happens so there is
this
little cute stray cat uh that comes here
every night
to kind of like hang with peachy from
behind
the door and i feed it sometimes because
so cute
and yeah so if anybody wants a cute
straight cats i got one right here
so you are going to hear a bunch of
meows because pc likes to
um convince me to let him out so he can
chase the other cats
so um
actually queen d7 is not a good move
because queen d7
takes over here and um
bishop d3 interesting but simply takes a
check
uh you take back and just i mean i
usually strip d1 also works
and this is not really i mean i don't
really see this having too much for
anybody
queen d7 is not the good move the the
most accurate move is actually quincy
aids and i was so
so so proud of myself for finding these
moves
and um yeah
and it didn't really work out at the end
so it was very painful
um so as you can see bishop a8
oh boy you really can't do this
um because i mean
the game actually turned out this way
but the thing is
this queen is going to be monstrous i
got two bishops
well i have two bishops in exchange for
one pawn and one brook
so i mean if i could somehow get these
bishops to work together that would be
uh
yeah that would be quite painful for
white so
in the game actually uh irina took on e7
first
rookie eight and then she took i took so
my whole idea was that
i understood that i can't really defend
this pawn and i can't really defend this
troop so i'm going to lose both of them
but the way to lose it was my choice so
i if i could take this pawn if this rook
back with the queen so something like
come here and then take it
that's that's what i should be looking
for so i could put my queen in the prime
position
um and now this is actually plus five
for black
so black is super winning and i messed
it up
so if you mess stuff up no you're not
alone
to be fair i messed it up in time
trouble
i had i remember i had very little time
on my clock
but still i should have i should have
played it much accurately bishop v6 was
a good choice
so my idea was that okay i need to eat
this pawn like no kidding that pond
gotta go uh but i couldn't just play
bishop f6 vision six was such an
easier way to go about it because yeah
so this should be six and now you see i
can't really eat over here because of
rookie
so i can save my queen
and irina she's a very experienced
player she knew she
had a bad position and she was trying to
fight
and confuse me and be super tricky
so she goes for c5 i finally go for
bishop f6
irk d8 i eat over here
and now we got this position so this is
still winning for black uh
but white still has this one pawn that
she could be quite hopeful about so what
i should have done
is the first thing is stabilize my
position
what are some of the threads in this
position third number one well my bishop
thread number two this back rank is
going to be painful for me
so the best thing to do in this position
just combining those two
was to play kg7 to avoid anything with
the back crank issues and to defend my
bishop
so my biggest problem in this endgame
was the fact that i
left my pieces defenseless
so don't do that and that is one of the
things that i'm hoping
not to do not to go through again
in this u.s championship starting from
tomorrow
i don't want to have my pieces hanging
so i probably that's
well my goal for the interview don't i
don't want to leave hanging pieces
ever never never no pieces left behind
yeah so
i um didn't really do that in this
position i just went king bishop e5
uh queen b7 now you see this is getting
actually super active
i'm trying to activate my pieces as well
but
it's just not enough because well with
cleaning for i still need to
i think my problem was that i i had the
idea that i
wanted to um go for the king
but that was kind of a it wasn't a very
uh smart idea because well i should have
had
both ideas of going for the king and
pushing the pawn or something like that
the championship so i'm annie um
there is an open tournament there is
open championship
and there's a woman's specific but we
play in the women's specific because
um well by rating
none of the women qualify so it's a
painful truth
but it is what it is it's not like
there's any rules against women playing
in the open section but
they're not just strong enough
and that is very painful for me to say
so
anyways um let's get back to the
chest of it um
yeah so rookie one again um oh i think
again like here i think another my
second biggest mistake
was that i uh didn't
do too tricky so
i uh kind of should have played with
queen a5
i should have been tricky because we
were both in time pressure
and um yeah i should have went with
queen eight five
okay so queen a5 that i didn't do
stats that stuff i simply
played bishop d4 and you can see bishop
d4 was already a huge mistake
because bishop d4 now she could actually
take over here
and go for something with uh sorry
queen e7 that was one of the things she
could do a little bit better
and um well
oh boy my cat is so playful
and all right so bishop d4 was a mistake
for me and not just because
the bishop on d4 is weird because i
needed this bishop to stay here to
control the c7 square so bishop d4 was
already a little out of the coordination
and in this position i remember that i
made another
weird move i went for queen c4 you see i
shouldn't be doing these moves i should
i should have this king here i should
have this bishop
save um
now this is getting really dangerous
because well
um this bishop is pinned this pawn is
beginning to you know
really get painful i played bishop d5
queen f4
and so here i actually uh should have
taken bishop takes c6 earth c1
queen d5 i should have continued with
this way
and uh this would be still pretty hard
to try and win but black does have the
upper hand however i made the
mistake slash illusion of queen c3
queen c3 i just don't know what was i
thinking because queen c3 i'm just
attacking a rook
a very um it wasn't very thoughtful
queen c3
rook c1 and well what i'm trying what am
i trying to do i'm not really attacking
anything
i'm not really uh stopping anything that
was like
that was the that was the horrible
mistake
and interestingly enough it was on move
uh 37
so right before the uh right before we
uh we would get the 40th move and gets
the uh 30 extra minutes
yeah and we entered this position i had
to give up a bishop and
now this was actually quite hard to
even try to keep it raw and even as an
experienced player g4 the best move so i
wouldn't have h5s and
um i tried my best but it wasn't enough
and the game ended in a painful loss
uh i'm gonna just show it to you super
quickly because there's not really much
to talk about
in this end game uh there are again
there are different
variations in this specific endgame that
black
could try to form a fortress and
hold the draw but this isn't one of them
especially with the f and g
pawns i just tried to make it harder for
her to win
but coming from that gorgeous position
to this
was also just i was mentally crushed
ha crushed and yeah i just
tried to shuffle around a little and
yeah i just i believe i just resigned
over here yeah this is just a super lost
position
yeah so this was one of those really
painful
uh games for me because it was such a
beautiful start such a great
middle games i did calculation strategy
i had a
great mix of those and just one move
is kind of blew it and it wasn't like i
didn't really blunder a piece or
something i just blundered the idea
and i blundered the whole um
i blundered the the peace coordination
i kind of yeah i started to just make
moves i didn't really
follow a specific plan and i got really
punished
still kind of hurts so yeah
i'm gonna be playing um the u.s
championship starting tomorrow
so tune in watch me either get crushed
or crush
bunch of people actually i'm not playing
arena tomorrow so i guess that's analogy
it doesn't work
but yeah um so um george
i would ideally want to go deeper in
this endgame but we are out of time
and um eventually at some point we will
go
a little deeper in the rippers bishop
and the specific pawn structures that
follows
but yeah make sure to tune in tomorrow
and yeah i'm gonna go
get myself a little uh t hat on the back
just
get a little air after this game oh my
god this is painful
all right so um have a good rest of your
day well here's tonight and make sure to
watch the us championships tomorrow